i'm dave rubin and i'm host of the
reuben report a show where i try to have
reasonably informed conversations about
politics
we're all about to sit around the table
for thanksgiving with our loved ones at
one of the most divisive periods in
american history
there are some of you who don't want to
see your relatives or have disinvited
them due to disagreements about politics
and that's why it's more important than
ever to resist the urge to assume the
worst intentions
in our family and in our friends if
you're a democrat or a left-leaning type
don't assume that because your relative
voted for trump or is a republican that
they are a racist homophobic bigot
their reasons for thinking the way they
do may be more nuanced and complex than
you may think
if you're a trump voting republican
don't assume that your
liberal relatives are all socialists
wanting to throw out the constitution
there are sane liberals who are not
radical and don't align with the burn it
all down lefty crowd
there aren't many of those liberals left
but that makes it all the more important
to find them
and talk to them it's important to
understand and not forget that we
actually want
a lot of the same things we want to have
successful lives for us and our children
and others but we have different ideas
on how we can get there
what i do know is that we won't get
there by cutting people
out of our lives and making the walls of
our echo chambers taller
than they already are so you don't have
to agree with my politics or who i voted
for
but if you agree that we can only get to
a better world by trying to better
understand each other
not by ostracizing each other then share
this video
if you think it's a better idea to
assume the best in our opponents instead
of the worst
then share this video share it with
someone you're worried about getting
into a fight with
at thanksgiving share it with people you
know that you agree with
and share it with those who don't we can
only fix society's problems by working
together and trying to better understand
each other
so if you only agree with that message
alone share this so we can all get on
the same page
to start rebuilding the bridges we've
been so busy burning
all right now more importantly than any
of that get off social media
get hopped up on tryptophan and take a
nap
happy thanksgiving everybody if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell